and his nine-year-old body has been torn
apart by it
inside and out
he now has a new prosthetic leg courtesy
of the turkish-built hospital
inside the turkish-controlled buffer
zone of syria
these are people weary of war they want
syria back to themselves
but they want peace more
i don't want war he says i can't take it
assad ruined everything
we want security we want security
everyone wants to go back to their
hometown she says
whole families are affected even if like
11 year old renal you escape
injury she's had to learn how to cope
with her father's wounds
as well as his anger and grief
he not only lost his leg but also his
arm
and an eye and she's had to grow up fast
may god punish bashar al-assad he took
my only son
i want to earn my own living from my own
sweat
i don't want anyone's pity
it is tough on father and daughter
especially when you can't even hug each
other properly
in aleppo province safety is a relative
term
this is the buffer zone held by syrian
opposition troops
bolstered by the turkish military but
the white helmets are trawling this
olive grove
to find ordnance left behind when the
regime dropped dozens of cluster bombs
this is a small crater where one of the
cluster bombs exploded and they're still
finding many just scattered all over
this field
this factory was one of the targets
and because this field was so close
it's still prone they're still finding
these cluster bombs and weapons and
unexploded arsonary months sometimes
years after
many of these men have picked up
horribly mutilated children who found
bombs which have detonated
every time a child gets hurt he says i
feel partially responsible
a civil defense we have to work really
hard to clean the land
it's our big responsibility
whilst we're in al-bab a town once
overrun by isis and used as its base for
attacks on aleppo
we hear there's been a vehicle explosion
this
constant instability in what's being
called a safe zone
is what's likely to deter people from
returning here
we have terrorists here they're isis
terrorists and the separatist parties
the kurds
they are doing this causing all these
attacks it's the pkk
and isis and we have suffered from this
for a long time
since we were liberated until now we're
suffering from this
we're sending a message to the world to
find a solution
but the opposition forces want to show
they're here to
this is their army's elite unit the
alhamsa division
we were invited exclusively to see their
brand new base
the turkish flag is prominently
displayed alongside the syrian
opposition one
our guided tour is given by the
commander who is a defector from assad's
army
he was keen to press home they're no
longer a ragtag group of civilians
nor extremists as their critics claim
but a fighting force
backed largely by turkish funds and
turkish weaponry
and he warned even if the west don't
acknowledge it yet isis is still a
threat
with new supporters
[Music]
our message to the international
community is that isis still exists
in the desert in east syria under the
protection of bashar al-assad and the
kurdish sdf
there are three thousand isis fighters
and they're not finished yet
the danger is not over and it won't
finish unless you support us
the syrian opposition to finish off the
assad regime
at the edge of the buffer zone they hold
the line against syrian regime forces
with guns and sandbags sent by turkey
the commanders are realist they feel
deserted by friends
and any help is grabbed
how possible is it for you to hold on to
any of these positions without the help
of turkey
all over the place we have no other
choice we either fight with what weapons
we have or we die
withdrawing is not an option it doesn't
exist in our dictionary
our dictionary is revolution we're
continuing whatever happens
and turkey is the only one with us on
the ground with weapons and military
equipment
so they let the regime forces know that
they're here
holding them back with whatever help
they can get the price for that
may only emerge later alex crawford sky
news in aleppo province syria